[LAUGHTER]
>> Will: EVERYBODY IS
COMMENTING ON MY MUSIC.
THAT IS FREESTYLE.
NOW WE TALK ABOUT CRYPT OH
FREAKS SAM BANKMAN-FRIED.
AFTER LOSING BILLIONS OF
CUSTOMERS MONEY.
THE FRAUDSTERS FAMILY IS
APPARENTLY CALLING THE RAT
INFESTED BAHAMAS PRISON WHERE HE
IS BEING HELD AND ASKING IF HE
CAN GET SOME VEGAN MEALS.
THAT REQUEST IS NOT GRANTED
APPEAR AT ALL THE TALK ABOUT SAM
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH HIS FORMER
FLAME CAROLINE ELLISON?
BANKMAN-FRIED BLAMED HER FOR THE
CRYPTO EXCHANGE BUT SHE HASN'T
BEEN CHARGED SO RUMORS ARE
SWIRLING SHE FLIPPED ON HER
FORMER BOYFRIEND.
CONGRESS WAS TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE FRAUD.
BANKMAN-FRIED AND HIS CRONIES
PUMPED AND $95,000 IN DONATIONS
TO 11 LAWMAKERS WHO SERVED ON
THE COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING LAST
MONTH'S CLASS OF THE FTX DOUGH
EXCHANGE.
I HOPE YOU DON'T MIND ME SAYING
SANDRA DURING THE COMMERCIAL
BREAKS YOU SAID THIS ISN'T A
CAJON SEAS SCHEME.
>> Sandra: I DON'T GET THIS
THE COMPARISON TO A PONZI
SCHEME.
A PONZI SCHEME THE STUDENT
BUZZERS OF A PONZI SCHEME AND
YOU TAKE THE NEW INVESTORS AND
PAY OFF THE ORIGINAL INVESTORS.
>> Will: KEEP RAISING MONEY.
>> Sandra: FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME.
THIS WAS OUTRIGHT FRAUD.
THIS WAS OUTRIGHT THEFT.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY
AUTHORITIES SHOULDN'T HAVE
CAUGHT ON TO WHAT HE WAS DOING
EARLIER.
I ALSO SAID DURING THE
COMMERCIAL BREAK IF WE ARE GOING
TO GO THERE THE FT FDNY COVERING
DURING "AMERICAN REPORTS"
FLABBERGAST THING ON THESE
PROSECUTOR STOOD UP THERE LIKE
THEY DISCOVER THIS.
THIS CASE WAS HANDED TO THEM ON
A PLATTER WITH A BOW HERE THEY
DID NOT DISCOVER THIS.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IN THE
WAKE OF ALL OF THESE DONATIONS
TO DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS BUT
MOSTLY DEMOCRATS, YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS AND ASK YOURSELF,
"WHY IS THIS A MARKET THAT
CONTINUES WITHOUT THE
REGULATIONS MOST ASSET CLASSES
HAVE?"
THEY HAVE RULES AND REGULATIONS
BUT WHY WAS THIS EXEMPT FROM
THAT IN WAYS THAT STILL EXEMPT
FROM THAT?
WHY DO WE HAVE TO BEG FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN?
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN AND
THERE WERE RED FLAGS ALL OVER
THE WAY.
NOW, WE HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR ALL
THOSE WHO TURNED A BLIND EYE TO
THE SPIRIT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
HAD THEIR ACCOUNTS WIPED OUT
BECAUSE OF THIS AND THE FEDS DIE
THEY ARE PATTING THEMSELVES ON
THE BACK THIS WEEK.
>> Will: I WANT A CLASSIC
JESSE WATTERS TAKE WAY HE ASKED
FOR VEGAN MEALS AND PRISON IS
PERFECTLY REASONABLE.
>> Jesse: REASONABLE?
WELL, WHEN YOU'RE RICH, WHITE
STANFORD PARENTS CALL THE JAIL
AND ASKED THE WARDEN IF YOU CAN
CHANGE YOUR MEALS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE DIETARY RESTRICTIONS, YOU
CANNOT RECOVER FROM THAT.
THIS IS NOT SLEEP AWAY CAMP.
THIS GUY IS NOT IN FIRST CLASS
WHERE, WELL, I WILL HAVE THE
VEGAN ENTREE.
NO, THIS GUY IS IN JAIL AND WILL
BE IN JAIL FOREVER.
HE NEEDS TO GIVE THE CASH BACK
THAT HE SQUIRRELED AWAY AND GIVE
IT BACK TO THE PEOPLE HE STOLE
MONEY FROM.
AND THE GIRLFRIEND, IT LOOKS
LIKE, IS GOING TO FLIP AND SING.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
HAVE A PIER THERE IS NO LOYALTY.
THE REPUBLICANS KEEP SAYING THEY
GOT SO MUCH MONEY AND I'M SO
SICK OF HEARING THAT.
WE COULD ZOOM IN ON THIS HERE.
SEE THE BLUE PUSH MARK THE BLUE
OR DEMOCRATIC DONATIONS AND THE
RED ARE THE REPUBLICAN
DONATIONS.
IT IS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
IF YOU ADD IN THE EXECUTIVES AT
THAT FIRM DONATED, THAT IS ABOUT
$70 MILLION, AND THE DEMOCRAT
SPENT AND STOLE.
AND I WILL GET THAT MONEY BACK
FOR YOU AND GERALDO BECAUSE THAT
MONEY IS BOGUS.
IF YOU GET DIRTY MONEY FROM
STOLEN CASH AND THEN YOU WIN AN
ELECTION YOU CAN'T JUST SAY I'M
GOING TO GIVE IT TO CHARITY.
ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE IT TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION?
YOUR UNCLES CHARITY?
WHO WILL DOUBT DONATE IT BACK TO
THE NEXT CYCLE?
THAT IS NOT FAIR.
YOU CANNOT HAVE THESE, BECAUSE
THESE PUMPING UP THE SENATES.
YOU CAN'T HAVE GUYS STEALING
CASH FROM A DONATING TO
DEMOCRATS AND THEN DYING ON THE
HILL.
I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE THE MONEY
TO CHARITY.
YOU CAN DO THAT EVERY SINGLE
ELECTION IF YOU WANT TO.
ONE GUY GOES TO JAIL AND THEY
KEEP THE SENATE.
NOT FAIR COMING UP FOR HER!
>> Will: JESSICA?
>> Jessica: SO HE DIDN'T STEAL
THE SENATE.
>> Jesse: STILL PURCHASED WITH
FRAUDULENT MONEY.
>> Jesse: THAT IS CAPITALISM
MAY BE.
>> Jesse: NO, IT IS NOT!
>> Jessica: OKAY I THOUGHT I
WOULD TRY PURITY SHOULD GET BACK
THE MONEY AND I DON'T THINK
THE CHARITY IS GOOD ENOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW -- THERE
OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE SOMEBODY
IN CHARGE OF THIS BECAUSE A LOT
OF THIS MONEY WAS GIVEN TO YOU
WHICH PACKS THAT GIVES MONEY TO
VARIOUS AND ADULTS, ISSUES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WORKS.
JUST PICKING A CHARITY ANIMAL
CRUELTY OR WHATEVER DOESN'T HELP
THE PEOPLE THAT NEED THIS MONEY
BACK.
SO IT MAKES COMPLETE SENSE TO ME
VICTIMS FUND WHEN YOU WERE IN
PRISON AND HAVE A RELIGIOUS
REASON WHY YOU NEED A SPECIAL
MEAL.
THAT IS ONE THING.
IF IT IS JUST A DIETARY
PREFERENCE, THAT IS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
THEY WERE TO FIGHT DIETARY
MEALS.
AND I UNDERSTAND IT MIGHT NOT BE
WHAT YOU WANT TO PURE THE
GIRLFRIEND HAS A VERY STRANGE
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE FOR SURE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE STUFF AND
I KNOW THERE WERE MULTIPLE WOMEN
AROUND BUT IF SHE WILL FLIP ON
HIM, GREAT.
IT CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
CRAZIEST THINGS AND WATCHING ALL
OF THIS LIKE ON THE NBC WILD
WITH PEOPLE ATTACKING.
>> Dagen: IT IS NOT THAT HE
DID, HE RIPPED A LOT OF PEOPLE
OFF, PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
>> Will: THE GIRLFRIEND IS
SINGING?
>> Dagen: LET'S TALK ABOUT SAM
AC WHERE REFERRED TO FTX AS THE
NEXT JPMORGAN APPEAR AT THEIR
COVERAGE OF CRYPTO AND
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS COMPANY
THIS MAN HAS LED A NAUSEATING
EMBARRASSMENT.
WHAT DID YOU JUST ASK ME?
>> Will: IF THE GIRLFRIEND IS
SINGING?
>> Dagen: SHE HIRED WILMER
HALE AND SPOTTED IN
NEW YORK CITY LOWER MANHATTAN AT
A COFFEE BAR.
HE WAS CLEARLY THROWING, SPF WAS
POINTING TO HER UNDER THE BUS
AND ON THE TRADING DIVISION AND
ALL ALONG, THE TRADING DIVISION,
THE CUSTOMER MONEY WAS BEING
USED AT THE TRADING DIVISION.
>> Will: RIGHT.
>> Dagen: THE MONEY WAS BEING
FUNNELED OVER THERE.
HE WAS OVERSEEING IT EVEN WHEN
HIS NAME WAS NOT ON AS CEO.
WE WOULD MAKE AN EASY
PROSECUTION OF HIM IF SHE GETS
ON THE WITNESS STAND.
SCREWED, FINANCIAL DOCUMENTS,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF DIGITAL
INFORMATION AND EVIDENCE.
JUST HER TESTIFYING AGAINST HIM
WOULD REALLY BE ENOUGH HAVING
COVERED SO MANY OF THESE TRIALS.
TO SANDRA'S POINT, WHAT WENT ON
CERTAINLY THE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
ALL OF THESE DEMOCRATS PLAYED
INTO THIS.
BUT THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
COULD HAVE REGULATED THIS.
THEY REGULATE LITERALLY ANYTHING
TO DO WITH CONSUMER FRAUD.
YOU CAN'T SAY A BUCKET OF PAINT
COVERS 400 FEET AND ONLY COVERS
200 FEET.
THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU, WHERE ARE
YOU?
BECAUSE YOUR ONLY A LOT OF MOUTH
AND NO MOJO.
THE SECURITY EXCHANGE COMMISSION
AND THE TRADE COMMISSION THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, FRANKLY,
GAMBLING IS MORE REGULATED THAN
ANY OF THIS.
AND IT IS ALL BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTED TO STOP THE TRADING OF
THESE DIGITAL BEANIE BABIES.
EVERYBODY WAS HAVING A BLAST AND
MAKING SO MUCH MONEY.
IT IS THE REASON TIKTOK HAS
NEVER BEEN REGULATED.
AND NOW, EVERYBODY IN D.C. HAS
WOKEN UP TO IT.
EVERYBODY WAS GETTING RICH.
AND THE ALLURE OF CRYPTO WAS
ALWAYS AND STILL IS LARGELY THE
FACT THAT GET THE GOVERNMENT OUT
OF MY MONEY!
I HATE FIAT CURRENCY.
I WANT THE GOVERNMENT'S HANDS
OFF OF MY MONEY.
WELL, GUESS WHAT?
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT INVOLVED IN
YOUR MONEY.
IT IS JUST LIKE THE 1920s AND